Hey what's up guys it's Rob, and welcome to
my tutorial for the Epic 2-in-1 Paper Cup
Boomerang and Helicopter! Most people use their
cups to have a drink and throw it away. So I
thought "Is there some way that we can get this
cup so that when you threw it away it actually
came back?!" Well after a few cuts and folds the
paper cup becomes a fun two-in-one model that not
only spins down like a helicopter, but becomes an
amazing boomerang that comes back to you! It even
has a ninja star on the back that I thought would
look really cool when I designed it. And of course
it's a great boomerang for doing trick shots. It
not only works with a variety of paper cups, but
you can also throw it with your left and right
hands--try throwing two at the same time! So get
ready to learn the all-new Paper Cup Boomerang and
Helicopter. I'd like to take a moment to thank my
new Patrons Ximena and Adam. It was fun teaching
you on Zoom. I showed them the boomerang on my
Discord server and they definitely wanted to learn
it. If you want your chance to get a shout out, have
your idea featured, access to my discord server,
or get one-on-one help and more head over to
my Patreon and support me. For a limited time i'm
offering all new patrons a 30 minute zoom lesson.
You're going to need a paper cup and some
scissors. While it can work without tape,
some cups can be thicker or have outside
layers like these, making it harder to fold
and it might require some tape just to hold
the flaps down. Plastic cups won't work for the
boomerang but can work for the helicopter but
not as well as paper. Pure styrofoam won't work
but these paper coffee cups with paper inside and
soft foam exterior will work but might need tape
because they don't fold as well as regular paper.
Once you have the proper supplies let's do it!
We need to first take the cup and cut it into
eight equal sections like this. To start,
we're going to hold it on two opposite sides and pull
apart and flatten it as best we can and make two
really sharp pinches on the outside. We're only
folding the top of the rim not the entire cup. We
can take the scissors and cut the cup directly up
from the pinch in the rim all the way to the base
as straight as we can. Then we could do the same on
the opposite side, cutting it all the way from the
rim to the base. Now we could take the two edges of
each half and meet them together and make a pinch
directly in the middle of the rim just like this.
Turn it around and do the same on the other side,
meeting the two cut corners or edges of the rim,
holding them together rounding it and giving it
a pinch. Now, once again, we can cut it directly
on that pinch from the rim all the way to the
base on both sides. If it helps, you can make a mark
on the rim and draw a line to help you make nice
straight cuts. Or sometimes the cup has patterns
you can use to guide you as well. To ensure
you're cutting all the way to the bottom of the
inside, you could take the scissors and place them
on the inside of the cup to see it going all the
way down to the base just like this. Now, we can cut
the quarter sections into eighths by once again
folding the rim in half like this and making a
pinch. Do that for all four pieces, trying to ensure
that they are folded exactly in half. Once you've
made a pinch on all four of the sections hold them
and just like before cut them in half, trying to
divide them evenly down the middle of the section
so all eight pieces are about the same width.
Take your time and try to cut as straight and
vertically as you can. When you're finished, it
should look like this and just make sure you cut
all the way to the base on the inside of the cup.
Now we're going to look for the section that
has the joint or lip in it and fold that down
first. We're going to fold it down so that it is
flush completely with the base. It should fold
down easily and you shouldn't hear any rips if
you did cut all the way to the bottom of the cup.
Then, we're going to skip every other section and
fold them down so that it's flat with the base.
Continue until you have folded down four cup
sections and it should look just like this.
Now we could set it down on the table and flatten
the four sections which we just folded down.
I'm just going to make an "X" on the
sections we folded down with a marker.
Once we've done that, at this point this
is the "Helicopter Configuration" and if you
flip it over and spin it, it'll float down
as a helicopter, which i'll show a bit later (7:40)
At this point, we're going to fold down all of
the sections here.  The sections we marked with the
"X" are going to be the boomerang blades, while
the others are going to be interlocked like a
Ninja Star to create a "flap" or airfoil on each
blade.  Just like we did with the other sections,
fold down the last four sections and flatten
them out so they are even with the base.
If you're having difficulty doing this, make sure
you cut far enough. Set it down on the table and
make sure everything's nice and flat. Before you
try to make the boomerang, inspect it to make sure
the blades are relatively equal, flat and neat--not like this!  If it does you may want to toss
it and try it again. Now, we can mark the other
sections 1 to 4 in a clockwise direction.
Then we can cut off the very tip of the rim on
only those numbered sections. Then we're going to
take the two opposite sections in this case 1(one)
and 3 (three) and fold them inwards with the bottom
section folded UP on the left and the top section
folded DOWN on the right.  The inside edges should
not be overlapped, but touching. Then we could turn
it and do the same with sections 2 (two) and 4 (four),
folding them inwards the same exact way.
Once we've folded them in, we could press
down firmly. This is the same way that they
will be arranged when they are interlocked*
Now, we can open the numbered sections we just
folded inwards. We're going to now interlock
them in a clockwise direction, starting with 1 (one)
and then moving to 2 (two), 3 (three) and so forth.
We're gonna first fold down 1 (one) so that the left
side of it is on the edge of the cup base.
Then, we're going to fold 2 (two) on top of it, and then
3 (three) down on top of 2 (two). Now, the last one 4 (four) is
going to go on top of 3 (three) and underneath 1 (one). So
we're going to slide 1 (one) out from underneath 2 (two),
just like this, and create a little pocket or an
opening, like a little bridge. Then we could round
4 (four) off and curve it a little bit at the end and
push it through the opening underneath 1 (one).
Once it's tucked under, you can grab it on the other
side and pull it all the way through. To make sure
the sections are interlocked snugly, we're just
going to pull or tug on the two opposite sections
to ensure that they're tucked in all the way and
secure. Just press down. When we've done that
it should look something just like this. Now, you'll
see when we interlocked the sections on the back, it
created an overhang here on the other side of the
boomerang blades. You should notice that the flaps
will be counter-clockwise or on the left side of
the blade when they're facing directly upwards.
These will create an airfoil flap which we need to
fold down along the edge of the boomerang blade.
So fold down all the way so that it's flush with the
top of the blade and make a nice sharp crease.
We will do that now for the remaining three
airfoil flaps. Fold down along the top of the
blade and crease sharply. Finally, complete the last
one by folding it down and creasing and it should
look something like this.
If you find that theairfoils pop out
or stick up you can try taping them down at the very center here.
Just wrap the
lower third (1/3) with tape to keep it flat and secure.
To throw the helicopter, just make sure
that the four propellers are bent
upwards like this and the other ones are
facing down and haven't been folded yet.
Then, all you need to do is just throw it
from a height and give it a spin. So spin it!
To throw the boomerang, I'm going to take it
like this. You can take it in your right hand
like this and hold it with your two fingers on top
and your thumb right on the airfoil here
just like that. You can kind of rest it on the rest
of your fingers. I'm just going to flick my
wrist out, I'm just going to snap my wrist like that.
So take it and just snap your wrist out like that.
You can also take it in your hand on
one of the arms and flick it this way.
And you can use your left hand even
and just do the same kind of thing
It basically works with
all these different cups!
I hope you guys liked the video for the Paper
cup boomerang and the helicopter. If you did, be
sure to give it a thumbs up and smash that
like button down below! Also, don't forget
to Subscribe and click that Notification Bell if
you haven't already. Since i'm new to Patreon and
I'd like to connect with more fans since i've had
a lot of fun doing the private Zoom lessons, I'm
gonna make it for the next two months no matter
what tier you join i will give you a zoom lesson: a
30-minute lesson on whatever you'd like! So be sure
to check out my Patreon to support me. Also, leave
me a comment down below let me know what you'd
like to see next: more boomerangs, Rubik's cubes
or if you want to see this cool duct tape hat that
I made. Let me know and I will see you guys soon!